president trump rallies in el paso
beidou
responds and the government shutdown
deal is on the table i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
man i knew that 2020 was going to be
great i did not know that the circus was
going to be this much fun
all three rings of the circus have been
filled and there are more rings to come
more candidates thinking about entering
and all of them making fools of
themselves and it's just glorious we're
going to get to all of that
in just one second first let's talk
about your genetic profile we live in a
world where we have access to data that
gives us more personalized insights into
who we are
what's more personalized than your dna
the answer is nothing which is why you
should check out 23andme they allow you
to go beyond
ancestry to gain more personalized
insights about you based on your dna
take the elizabeth warren challenge and
see what your ancestry looks like and
whether you are in fact more native
american
than a united states senator but then
also make sure that you have all the
information about
your health and wellness they've got
things like the deep sleep report that
asks you and tells you actually based on
your genes whether you are more apt to
be a light sleeper or a deep sleeper
they've got a sweet versus salty taste
report which sort of explains your sweet
tooth versus your salty
your taste for salty saturated fat and
weight report which can tell you about
how your genetics may impact your body's
response to your diet so they've got
all sorts of great information i took a
23andme test you spit right into a tube
it's super easy
and then they just send you your
information online it is fun to look at
and not only that it gives you some
valuable information
about how you can best tailor your life
activities to meet your genetic needs
at 23andme all you have to do to get
that health and ancestry kit
is go to 23andme.com shapiro that's the
number two threeandme.com
shapiro again that is 23andme.com april
buy your kit today 23andme.com
slash apparel makes a great valentine's
day gift something fun and different
check them out 23andme.com
shapiro all right so last night
president trump held his first real
campaign rally
of 2020 and his first campaign rally
of 2020 was a blowout i mean there were
thousands and thousands of people who
showed up
gigantic crowd there on the border in el
paso and it was trump at his finest i
mean it was free-wheeling trump it was
trump doing what he does best just going
off on folks
it was pretty solid stuff so he began by
launching into an attack
on the green new deal and alexandro
ocasio-cortez's stupid frequently asked
questions and background or checklist
here he is going after aoc and it is
pretty spectacular
last week they introduced a massive
government takeover
that would destroy our incredible
economic aims they
introduced the so-called green new deal
[Applause]
it sounds like a high school term paper
that got a low mark
this is exactly right of course i mean
it's as though he listens to the show
since that's exactly what i said when it
came i said that this was
a paper that that should never have
gotten a c plus
in an english class from like eighth
grade which is exactly right
the president has a real benefit in 2020
that people are ignoring and that is
he will be running against a democrat
everybody in 2020 is looking forward to
the fact that trump has low approval
ratings
okay so he's around 40 42 44
and the going wisdom is that that's just
not popular enough to get reelected
that obviously is not true he was at 40
when he got elected in 2016.
and again democrats as we will get to
are interested in making fools of
themselves over and over
this primary fight not only is a lot of
dirty laundry going to be aired
but an enormous amount of leftism is
going to be pushed out into the public
square
because democrats have to outflank each
other if somebody gets to the left of
the rest of the crowd
suddenly they're distinguished from the
rest of the crowd in a race with 1 000
people
all you have to do to stand out is be
the one person wearing a different color
and in the democratic party primaries
the only way to do that is to outflank
everybody to the left you can't outflank
everybody to the right you can't be the
moderate in the race and somehow win
this thing
the progressive base just won't stand
for it as joe biden may be about
to learn so that means that trump is
going to be able to run against the
craziness of the democrats as i have
said
for literally three years at this point
all the democrats had to do was not be
crazy
and they just can't do it it is
pathologically impossible for democrats
not to be insane at this point
because trump has driven their base
totally and saying now does that mean
they're necessarily going to lose
should we get overconfident about this
thing no it doesn't mean the democrats
aren't necessarily going to lose
remember democrats thought the same
thing about republicans in 2016.
they thought that obama had driven the
right so insane that they nominated a
cartoon character
tv show host and then he was going to
lose because the right had been driven
crazy and then trump ended up winning so
it is quite possible for the left to be
both insane and also to win
it's a it's a risky situation in the
sense that
whoever is put up there for the
democrats is going to be incredibly
radical and that person does have
a 40 50 60 shot at winning depending on
what the circumstances are
but suffice it to say trump is going to
have a lot to run against it wasn't just
trump running against the democrats he
also went after the fact checkers in the
media again well deserved
you can keep your doctor remember that
28 times
[Applause]
that didn't happen turned out to be a
lie
hey where are the fact checkers you know
some of the most
dishonest people in media are the
so-called fact
checkers 28 times you can keep your
doctor
that didn't turn out to be what he said
they're coming
for your money and they're coming for
your freedom and it'll never happen
okay and that of course is exactly true
when he goes after the fact checkers
that is absolutely accurate we talked
yesterday about the washington post
covering for aoc so aoc lied about her
own release of the her green new deal
backgrounder and frequently asked
question
and the washington post refused to even
give her a pinocchio on the basis of
what was
an obvious lie the fact checkers are in
the democrat camp trump has a lot to run
on there
trump also stood by his el paso border
remarks there are a bunch of fact
checkers who are suggesting
that he was not telling the truth about
the building of the border wall in el
paso he stood by his comments anyway
i've been hearing a lot of things though
the wall didn't make that much of a
difference you know where it made a big
difference
right here in el paso i spoke to people
that have been here a long time
they said when that wall went up it's a
whole different ball game is that a
correct statement
i don't care whether a mayor is a
republican or a democrat
they're full of crap when they say it
hasn't made a big
difference i heard the same thing from
the fake news
they said oh crime actually stayed the
same didn't stay the same
went way down okay so he is not wrong
that crime continued to drop the crime
was already dropping by the time the
border fencing was put in place what did
drop were illegal border crossings stan
crenshaw tweeted out yesterday
a statistical chart showing that border
crossing illegal border crossings into
el paso dropped pretty dramatically
after the implementation of fencing so
trump isn't totally wrong
about this trump also had one of his
famous moments
protesters showed up and i don't know
what they think they're getting done by
doing this except for giving trump
something to bounce off of
what's amazing to me is how
short-sighted a lot of protesters are
you know i've had my share of protesters
and my college speeches they come and
they try to disrupt i don't know what is
going through their heads do they
actually think they are accomplishing
something good
i guess that because they are patted on
the back by many members of the left
because they are seen as people speaking
truth to power that this gives them the
impetus to go out there and act like
fools
but all they're really doing is giving
the president something to club into
submission
as i've been saying about president
trump for legitimately years at this
point the man is a hammer in search of a
nail
sometimes he hits a nail and it's
incredibly satisfying sometimes it's a
baby and it's a lot less satisfying
when the protester shows up they're
giving him a nail that he can hit
and president trump takes out that
sledgehammer and just wails away at it
rather than waiting online for five days
for nine days for three weeks
where do these people come from where do
they come from
[Applause]
they go back home to mommy they get
punished when they get home
that's great i mean what can you say
about that he's not wrong
it's that's that's good stuff and this
is what where the president's his best
is off the cuff
honestly he is very quick on his feet
when it comes to rebutting people who
don't like him
and it comes off really well in in crowd
settings he also went after ralph
northam in virginia again democrats
providing him an endless font of
material all trump has to do in 2020
is just sit back gather material and
then make fun of it
hey really that's all he has to do he
just has to play kind of low rent jon
stewart
all he has to do is let the democrat say
things and then he just comes out
and he mocks them or repeats their
comments then the media go crazy how
could trump repeat his comments
so trump goes after ralph northam and
it's just
i mean this is solid stuff this is good
material from the president of the
united states
listen is it lincolnesque no but you
knew what you were getting when you
elected president trump
the guy's been this way for years i i'm
still i
honestly i find it rather hilarious and
simultaneously off-putting
when you see some of the folks who
didn't vote for trump in 2016
and i didn't vote in the 2016 election
for president when you see people
who are so anti-trump on the right that
they can't appreciate the humor of what
president trump does
as though it's a brand new shock it's a
brand new terrible thing every time he
does something funny
it's a brand new insult to the office
can you get off your high horse for just
a second barack obama did an interview
with a lady who once bathed in cheerios
can you get off of it like the office of
the presidency it's been degraded for a
little while now
president trump isn't anything new in
this respect can you just appreciate the
humor for what it is
like instead of sitting here and being
the fuddy duddy can you just appreciate
that
this is some funny stuff like come on it
is it's funny here's the president going
after ralph northam and it's pretty
hilarious
so in virginia the governor he's got a
little publicity lately
i like him keeps us out of the papers i
like
i'd like to find a few more guys like
this one he almost moonwalked his wife
stopped him
darling darling it would be
inappropriate i want to see somebody
try and imitate michael jackson
in the moonwalk this would not have been
a good scene his wife saved him
come on that's great stuff it's just
great i mean look
it's true it's true and it's funny
because it's true he also then repeated
ralph northam's comments about abortion
and the media went crazy he suggested
that ralph northam had said that a baby
would be born alive during an abortion
they would keep the baby comfortable
while the parents and the doctor decided
whether to execute it or not and people
were like
how dare he ralph northam never said
that he basically quoted northam
word for word so this was trump at his
finest last night if trump does this
just this comedy routine all the way up
until 2020 everyone will go home happy
the economy
if it's still good we'll be good
everybody will be in a good mood because
this is some funny stuff
but he saved his best repartee for beta
o'rourke
he saved his best stuff for beta
o'rourke so here's the president of the
united states now
remember this rally was was being held
at the
el paso county coliseum and it was also
broadcast outside the coliseum on a
giant screen
because there was an overflow crowd of
several thousand people because
it was like 45 degrees out there but the
president of the united states and el
paso
you're gonna go and you're gonna see it
in just a second i'm gonna explain to
you what he did to beta o'rourke who's
holding a rally
maybe 500 a thousand feet away i'll
explain in just
one second first let's talk about the
best valentine's day gift that
you can give in terms of chocolatey
goodness this year i'm talking of course
about cherries berries now i
had never tried cherries berries they
sent over a package of kosher
sherry's berry stuff oh my
god i mean this is some of the best
material ever put
on planet earth and you can be giving
some of this to your loved one this
valentine's day
for the not expensive price of 19.99
never go wrong with their signature
dipped valentine strawberries dipped in
milk dark or white chocolatey goodness
for any discerning palette she will fall
in love with every bite topped with
decadent toppings chocolate chips heart
and glitter sparkles
always fresh always tasty always worth
the wait perfect
companion to a candle at dinner a
bouquet of flowers or a night on the
town it is so good i mean
legitimately like my wife and i have
probably gained 73 pounds
since we started getting sherry's
berries because we can't stop eating it
it is that delicious
valentine's made easy it arrives fresh
with 100 cherries berries guarantee
trips anywhere nationally give sweet
somethings to your long distance love
send her that valentine's gift of her
dreams at the price of your dream
starting at just 19.99 plus shipping and
handling
plus order now and make this valentine's
really special by getting double the
berries for just 10 bucks more so it's a
solid deal go to berries.com
click on the microphone and enter my
code bend show at checkout that's
b-e-r-r-i-e-s dot com
click that microphone enter code bend
show at checkout berries.com
enter code ben show order today i
promise you these
these chocolatey goodness wonderful i
mean it's like it's a taste of god it's
just it's the greatest thing ever
sherry's berries berries.com click that
microphone enter the promo code ben show
all right so
trump saved his finest mockery for beta
o'rourke who's holding a counter rally
now remember
el paso is in o'rourke's district so
you figure a work would have drawn a
huge crowd we'll get to beto's counter
rally in just a second
president trump spared no mockery for
beta o'rourke
went directly at him and yeah this come
on like
we live in a wwe world now so you can
either root for the undertaker
or you can root against the undertaker
okay that's that's all that's going on
here
and here comes the undertaker from the
top rope with the flying elbow
go a young man who's got very little
going for himself
except he's got a great first name
he is he challenged us
so we have let's say 35 000 people
tonight
and he has 200 people 300 people
not too good in fact what i do
what i would do is i would say that may
be the end of his
presidential bid but he did challenge it
so great
come on that's such good stuff you just
got
president trump he's a showman he's a
showman and he's at the center of this
three-ring circus just making beta
o'rourke jump through rings
lit on fire it's phenomenal it's
it's such good stuff so meanwhile beta
o'rourke was giving his own rally
and things were not going all that great
for for beta o'rourke so a few things
were going poorly for bitter work one
as you can actually see from the footage
in the background of beta o'rourke's
speech is a giant screen
of president trump speaking and beta
o'rourke he's now become a paid a parody
of beta o'rourke
so beethoven has been trying to do his
obama impersonation for a couple of
years now
and it was pretty good impersonation
when it was subtle
now he's got the whole arm waving thing
big arm motions
for 2020 he's broken out the full on
marionette
posture for 2020 and so he starts
talking about
standing for america and against walls
he is saying this next to a fence that
separates israel
from the trump rally and also about
a thousand feet from the actual border
of el paso which as it turns out is
covered with a lot of fencing so here is
vader o'rourke railing against walls and
fences
honestly if democrats want to make this
their run go for it man go for it
we stand for america and we stand
against
walls we know
that there is no bargain in which we can
sacrifice
some of our humanity to gain a little
more
security we know that we deserve
and will lose both of them if we do
okay no one knows what he's talking
about but he's making big arm motions
really awkwardly so
it is amazing how so many of these
democratic candidates seem somewhat
attractive and interesting
on first glance and then when they give
a big campaign rally suddenly they look
like parodies of themselves
we will show you the most hilarious
moment of beto's rally in
just one second so the funniest thing
that happened at beto's rally is that
again he staged it too close to trump's
rally there were like a few hundred
people at bato's rally
we still haven't seen a complete far
shot of beto's rally to see how many
people showed up at his rally as opposed
to trump's
so beto is giving his speech and in the
background in the background
president trump's walk-on music is
drowning out beta o'rourke so
it literally is wwe it's some guy in the
center of the ring going
i'm going to take the undertaker and
then it's like whose music is that
it's the undertaker's music oh my god
here in one of the safest
cities in the united states of america
and the cheers are not at his rally the
cheers are from the other rally
for president trump now i don't know who
worked out the stagecraft for beta
o'rourke
my goodness guys i recommended that beta
o'rourke do a rally at the same time as
president trump
but not like right there with 20 of his
friends
that looks not great that turns out to
be a terrible terrible idea also
it's not real great when some of the
people who show up to your rally are
actually carrying mexican flags
that's not particularly wonderful people
were hawking beto 20 20 buttons and
holding signs and they were selling beto
shirts and then there were a few folks
who showed up with actual
mexican flags at the beta counter rally
which when you're trying to make the
case that you're standing up for texas
is not actually a wonderful wonderful
idea so
a bad night for for beta o'rourke but
that's not
a great shock the democrats in 2020 are
all struggling a little bit
so there are a couple stories about
kamala harris that have come out today
both of them are just glorious
story number one about kamala harris the
democratic front runner for 2020. we
call her the democratic frontrunner not
only because she's polling pretty well
at this point
but because she fulfills the
intersectional checkboxes she's black
and she is a woman that's all you need
in the democratic primary to mean that
you're going to win 15 to 20 percent of
the vote
pretty much automatically according to
the new math and i'm not saying this 538
is saying this nate silver is saying
that there are actual segments of the
democratic party that can be labeled
black and hispanic you can just label
them by race
so if you don't like me saying it talk
to lefty nate silver the pollster
okay so here's a story that's not going
to be great for kamala harris
it turns out that kamala harris her big
threat is going to come
not from her right because she's too
radical it's going to come from her left
because it turns out that she was a
prosecutor for a long time in the state
of california now i think she was a
garbage prosecutor the crime rates went
up while kamala harris was attorney
general of the state
she was actively involved in changing
the language on some of the referenda in
the state of california to loosen crime
regulations
so that people would be released from
prison early and so that certain
felonies would then be prosecuted as
misdemeanors she was a very very bad
attorney general but
even being in the law enforcement system
according to the left makes you a career
narc
you are now a person who is stamped with
the badge of infamy you once worked
for law enforcement so kamala harris is
trying to live that down
by suggesting that she was a subversive
narc she was she was really a cool
person
she was super cool so she was asked on a
show called the breakfast club
whether indeed she has ever smoked pot
and here was her supremely awkward
answer
have you ever smoked i have okay and i
and i inhaled i didn't i did it
[Laughter]
it was a long time ago but yeah
hey hey okay so she's cool because she's
mug pot everybody's fun everybody's
enjoying the fact that kamala hair
smoked pot and also has a really awkward
hilary-esque laugh
yeah it is a weird people have weird
quirks not unique to kamala harris
everybody has sort of a weird quirk when
when things get awkward
how do you respond and for kamala hara
she goes to her awkward laugh which is
very much like the hillary clinton
awkward laugh
it's like nobody said anything really
funny here senator but you're kind of
laughing weird
that interview went on and then things
got a little dicey because it turns out
she was an undercover cop it so what was
they asked her what was playing in the
background when young kamala was hitting
a joint she said
oh yeah definitely snoop tupac for sure
so basically the only time she smoked
pot was back in college and she was
listening to snoop
or tupac there is only one problem
tupac's first album came out in 1991.
snoop's first album came out in 1993 how
do i know all this
because as you know i'm a rap
connoisseur obviously
no i mean somebody else tweeted this
okay two box first album came out in
snoop's first album came out in 1993.
kamala harris graduated college in
1986. so unless she got hold
of the audition tapes for tupac and
snoop
some five to seven years before they
actually premiered their work
this is bull so one of two things is
true either kamala harris
smoked pot in college and also smoked
pot a lot later than college as in when
she was a d.a because this by this time
she was a d.a
so she was token while she was
prosecuting people for toking presumably
either that is the case or she's just
lying about having smoke pot whatever it
is
as as was comfortably smug or david
birch basically she's a character from
21 jump street
she that's that's what she that's what
she is now she's
i'm i'm so cool i'm one of the kids also
i'm 50
000 years old also i don't remember what
was playing on the radio it was probably
she's like when i was in college what
were you playing it was lady gaga lady
gaga
wasn't born yet senator it doesn't
matter
good times to senator harris also it
turns out that narc harris
she apparently wanted she tried to stop
the reduction of california's
overcrowded prisons now how does this
mesh
with my contention that she was soft on
crime and tried to let people out of
prison
well the answer is that she didn't want
to prosecute additional people and put
them in jail
she just wanted to keep the people in
jail who were there there
so that they could fight wildfires i am
not kidding you
article from the daily beast apparently
lawyers for harris wrote in a filing
with the court extending two for one
credits to all minimum custody inmates
at this time
would severely impact fire camp
participation
a dangerous outcome while california is
in the middle of a difficult fire season
and severe drought what does that mean
well the lawyers say that california
they said that california met benchmarks
and argued that if certain political
parolees were given a faster track out
of prison
it would negatively affect the prison's
labor programs where certain inmates
were
fighting california wildfires for two
bucks a day which is significantly below
minimum wage
in the state of california they also
noted that draining the prisons of
minimum custody inmates would deplete
the labor force both internally and in
local communities where low-level
non-violent defenders worked for pennies
on the dollar collecting trash and
tending to city parks
so narc harris out there talking about
how cool she was when she was smoking
pot
while listening to people who had not
yet released albums she also was arguing
and her office was arguing that we
should keep prisoners in prison
so that they could work for low wages so
slave slave labor for the state of
california
yeah things are going to be great for
kamala harris and it's not just kamala
harris
it gets even better so wait until you
hear what cory booker
is now proclaiming on the campaign trail
ah these candidates where do they come
up with these folks as president trump
where they come up with them i don't
even know go back home to miami
we can get this in just a second first
let's talk about your second amendment
rights so if you love your second
amendment rights this is for you listen
up
you a law abiding citizen who knows how
to use a firearm you're about to get
five free chances to win
a brand new ar15 as you know i'm a proud
member of the uscca
an organization that provides education
training and legal protection
for responsible gun owners like you and
me and they want to give you
one thousand dollars to buy the ar-15
that you have been dreaming of you know
the much maligned ar-15 which is
basically just
a normal semi-automatic rifle if you
want in you have to hurry and remember
you get five free chances to win if you
act right now entry is quick and easy
but it's almost over it all ends next
week just text
win to 87222 to lock in your entries
oh and as an extra guaranteed bonus
they're also going to send you a free
concealed carry guide just for entering
great information the folks at uscca
also have
tremendous educational resources legal
resources
not only are the folks at uscca on a
mission to help every responsibly armed
american protect their family
with complete confidence they love
giving away free guns to those
law-abiding citizens but you are running
out of time
don't miss your last opportunity at
getting the ar-15 you have always wanted
text win to eight seven two two two
right now
again that's win two eight seven two two
two win two eight seven
two two two all right so here's what we
have learned in
the past 24 hours beta o'rourke is a
marionette who can't draw a crowd in his
hometown
kamala harris is an arc and cory booker
is
cory booker because man cory booker
so this is according to the washington
free beacon senator cory booker said the
planet can sustain
people eating meat as the 2020 hopefully
aims to become the first vegan president
booker told the vegan magazine veg news
which i'm sure is just riveting stuff
like did you open up the mailbox every
saturday to read
the vegan magazine veg news where you're
just like oh man
look at that cucumber man this center
fold of a salad
unbelievable booker earlier this month
told
veg news that he became vegan after
coming to the realization that eating
eggs
didn't align with my spirit
weird realization while claiming he does
not want to lecture americans on their
diets booker said americans need to be
nudged into fake
cheese because the planet cannot sustain
the environmental impact
of the food industry you see the planet
earth moving towards what is standard
american diet booker said
we've seen this massive increase in
consumption of meat produced by the
industrial animal agriculture industry
the tragic reality is this planet simply
can't sustain billions of people
consuming industrially produced animal
agriculture because of environmental
impact he said it's just not possible
weird because the planet a century ago
had like 2 billion
3 billion people now we have some 8
billion people most of those people
are subsisting on a lot more meat than
people were a century ago
things are okay things are kind of okay
it turns out you know what we're really
good at doing
growing cows killing them and eating
them and also they taste delicious
now this is coming from somebody who
actually has a little bit of moral
sympathy for the vegan position or at
least the vegetarian position
the position that animals have a certain
level of sentience and killing them
may be a morally questionable behavior
in 100 years people may look back on us
and say
wow you were killing animals to eat them
that seems kind of barbaric i actually
have a little bit of sympathy for that
position
not enough sympathy to make me stop
eating chicken or steak but some
sympathy at the very least
but booker is doing this in the worst
and stupidest possible way
he's saying the reason that you
shouldn't eat meat is not for moral
reasons because you have objections
you shouldn't eat meat because the
planet can't help
the planet can't sustain you eating meat
except for again
the population skyrocketing over the
past 50 to 100 years
and people eating more meat not less
booker says the devastating impact of
greenhouse gases produced by the meat
industry
is just not practical so he too like aoc
is deeply worried about farting cows
he says the numbers just don't add up we
will destroy our planet
unless we start figuring out a better
way forward when it comes to our climate
change
and our environment booker said his
vegan journey began in 1992
after reading gandhi's biography he said
he wants to make the existing model of
the food industry obsolete
he's going to have to come up with a
better way of feeding billions of people
because you know what it turns
out is very very protein intense meat
people need
protein if you can find a better way to
generate these products i'm all ears man
but if you are going to talk about
starving people who need cheap meat to
survive
because you have moral objections to
cow farts not as much sympathy he says
you never change things by fighting what
exists in reality to change something
you got to build a new model that makes
the existing model obsolete
that's the deal here american consumers
should not be told what to eat but if
you provide viable alternatives in some
cases that taste even better
and if people have more information if
we consumers are informed about whatever
it is
the dangers of the overuse of plastics
all the way to the conditions in which
animals that we are consuming are being
treated he says that his non-vegan
friends love vegan foods like his
favorites
vegan pancakes and vegan stuffed french
toast
he says i've seen incredible vegan
cheese shops popping up around the
country and my friends who are lovers of
cheese just can't tell the difference
okay again as somebody who's there
there's a pretty good vegan restaurant
here in town that's kosher and it's good
is it as good as you know the natural
thing
no it is not you're just gonna break it
to you
okay vegan cheese not as good as regular
cheese
okay and i say this is a person who's
constantly used to eating air sats foods
because for example i can't eat pork
because i'm a jew so we have
kind of soy products that substitute
i guarantee that my friends who do eat
pork here i have a feeling they might
not like the soy products quite as much
so cory booker talking about how we all
need to become vegan so
that's going to be just wonderful so the
democrats really
are they sending their best apparently
they are bill de blasio that
crazy nut job who throws groundhogs is
headed to new hampshire
as he contemplates his run for the
presidency he's a communist but i guess
that's
kind of road at this point for
democratic candidates he is now
talking about running for president so
he's going to outflank everybody on the
far left he's actually going to launch
his campaign
from cuba he's traveling to nashua new
hampshire there he's going to meet with
mayor jim donchess and may chat with
locals at a diner
i do love this stuff about presidential
politics is where we all pretend
that this is what normal politicians do
what normal politicians do is they just
go to random places and stop at diners
when's the last time you stopped at a
diner just like a random diner
in the middle of nowhere probably not
that often probably you have like your
local eateries that you go to but
politicians apparently spend their days
finding babies to pat on the head
and diners to go to i promise you by the
way when he walks into a diner in nashua
new hampshire nobody's gonna know who he
is
he's gonna walk in people can be like
who's that big geeky guy and why is he
carrying a groundhog
and why is he wearing a che guevara
t-shirt that's weird
on friday evening de blasio will drive
to concord where he will meet with local
organizers of the group rights and
democracy new hampshire which describes
itself as part of a movement across the
region to counter the influence of money
in politics
apparently he is his his people are
are telling uh the because people are
telling the press
that he wants to make sure ideas like
pre-k for all paid personal time and
mental health are on the table as
democrats debate the party's vision
for the future everybody in the pool
every single person is going to run for
president and it's going to be delicious
so that is pretty excellent stuff okay
in just a minute
i want to get to the media defending the
fresh faces of the democratic party so
fresh
so face we're gonna get to that in just
a second but first you have to go over
and subscribe at dailywire.com for 9.99
a month you too can subscribe
to dailywire.com when you do you get the
rest of the show live you get two
additional hours of the show later in
the day
i mean we are bringing you the best
material like all day long basically we
have a 24-hour show here
and you can be part of it when you
become a subscriber for 99 dollars a
year you get this
the very greatest in all beverage
vessels the leftist tier is how to call
tumblr
cast your eyes upon it and despair as
alexander did when he realized there
were no more worlds to conquer
go check that out for 99 a year plus
tonight 7 p.m central the latest stop on
my young america's foundation tour
brings me to the university of alabama
i'm be making the ultimate case against
abortion you're not going to want to
miss that event if you can't make it
tonight
not a problem you can also watch the
speech online at yaf.org
live so you'll be able to watch every
melting snowflake in real time the q a
is always the best part again
that is 7 p.m central at university of
alabama i hope to see you there and if
not i hope you will see me later so go
check that out plus subscribe over at
youtube or itunes leave us a review it
always helps with our ranking
thank god the show continues to grow
extraordinarily thanks for telling all
your friends about it
and thanks for telling your parents
about it and who many of whom are
listening on our talk radio program
later in the afternoon
it really is a cool thing and thank you
for being a part of it we are the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
okay so as all of this continues it is
wonderful to watch the media defend the
fresh
faces of the democratic party so much
freshness so
much faceness so ilhan omar you will
recall is an anti-semite
she has a long anti-semitic record she
has lots of anti-semitic stuff like all
the time and then over the weekend
she was like the jews and their shekels
are paying for israel's support and
people like what do you mean
congresswoman and she was like
apac and then the democratic the
democratic higher ups like
could you apologize for that please and
she was like okay i apologize but also
the jews and apac
and then the media responded to that by
saying look she apologized why can't you
just leave this stuff alone
it's enough right i mean come on leave
her alone she's afresh she's a face
she's a fresh face come on
well i'm going to show you some tape of
ilhan omar and we'll determine if she
sounds truly
regretful at her anti-semitism gonna go
with no
i don't want to prejudge this for you
but you're going to go with no
so here she was walking through congress
and she was asked if she regrets her
comments
her answer not really
i'm pretty sure that was stated in my
statement were you surprised by
the um the criticism always surprised
are you worried about losing committee
assignment absolutely not
okay so she is an angry angry human
right she is very upset about all of
this
does does that seem like somebody who
really has learned her lesson or does
that seem like somebody who's pissed
that they were
called out does that seem like a
teenager who's pissed that their mom
caught the pot and they found the pot in
the top drawer
like kamala harris are they
it doesn't matter she look she is an
anti-semite she three weeks ago had to
apologize for anti-semitism then three
weeks later she had to apologize for
anti-semitism
so start your clocks now it has been one
day since accident
because in three weeks they're gonna
have to reset that clock again is she
going to lose her committee assignments
of course she's not going to lose her
committee assignments
steve king the congressman from iowa
said that white nationalism shouldn't be
a term
of of castigation it shouldn't be a bad
term he lost all of his committee
assignments
as he should have republicans punished
him ilhan omar
said the jews are paying for support for
israel
and everybody in the democratic party
just shrugged or even better
members of the left suggested that the
real problem with her comments was not
that she was anti-semitic
the real problem is that it gave
credence to the right that it gave the
right room to run michelle goldberg who
is
again one of the repository of
intellectuals over at the new york times
by which i mean
that which intellectually swirls the
drain in your toilet
so she has a piece today in the new york
times it is called ilhan omar's very bad
tweets
left-wing anti-semitism is a gift to the
right
i love that angle so normally when we
say anti-semitism is bad
usually we say it's bad because it's you
know bad
and so if i were to write a column about
steve king i would say that
white nationalism is bad i wouldn't say
it's a gift to the left i'd say it's
bad that's just bad it turns out that
hating jews
bad thing according to the left hating
she was only bad when you say it out
loud
and it backfires on you that's when it
gets kind of awkward so michelle
goldberg
has a full column about all of this she
says last october
after a crude mail bomb was found in
george soros's mailbox representative
kevin mccarthy the california republican
who is now the house minority leader
tweeted we cannot allow soros steyr and
bloomberg to buy this election
the tweet since deleted was referring to
tom steyer and michael bloomberg both of
them like soros jews who are often the
object of anti-semitic conspiracy
theories
speaking on cnn steyer who had also been
sent to mailbomb described mccarthy's
tweet as straight-up anti-semit
as a straight-up anti-semitic move by
the way it was not
tom steyer is a very wealthy person who
gives a lot of money to politics
michael bloomberg does the same so does
george soros that is not the same thing
as saying
the jews are buying support for other
jews on the basis of their jew money
which is what ilhan omar said she was
saying that jewish money stands behind
support for the jewish state
it is not anti-semitism to say michael
bloomberg gives a lot of money to
anti-second amendment causes that is a
fact
it is not anti-semitism to say that tom
steyer spends a lot of money
on environmental causes that is a fact
and it is not
it is not a a slanderer or an
anti-semitic libel he suggests that
george soros spends a lot of money on a
lot of left-wing
crazy causes that is absolutely true
it is however a lie to suggest that
jewish money is behind american support
for israel
that is not true in the slightest
nonetheless michelle goldberg is very
angry
against republicans because after all
when nilhan omar a democrat says
something bad about jews
you obviously have to talk about kevin
mccarthy she says
it would have been easy enough for
either omar or rashida talib to point
out mccarthy's cynical
hypocrisy instead omar responded with a
blindly incendiary tweet quoting puff
daddy's ode to the power of money
it's all about the benjamin's baby when
an editor at the foreword a jewish
publication
asked who omar thinks is paying american
politicians to be pro-israel
she responded aipac consciously or not
omar invoked a poisonous anti-semitic
narrative about jews using their money
to manipulate global affairs
i do enjoy the consciously or not
addendums here
it's funny how people on the left will
immediately apply those
those adjectives and modifiers to
situations that are clearly conscious
el hanan is exactly what she is saying
as i mentioned on yesterday's
radio show ilhan omar is scheduled
on february 23rd to speak alongside an
actual terror supporter
i mean this this is not a person who's a
babe in the woods when it comes to these
subjects in 2013 she gave an interview
where she laughed about hamas and
hezbollah alongside a host who calls
israel the jewish isis
so michelle goldberg says on monday
afternoon nancy pelosi and the rest of
the house democratic leadership rebuked
omar and called on her to apologize for
her use of anti-semitic tropes and
prejudicial accusations about israel's
supporters
it was a depressing fall from grace for
someone who just a few weeks ago was
feeded as a path-breaker
a refugee from somalia who alongside
talib rose to become
one of america's first two muslim
congresswomen omar herself
has been subject to vicious islamophobic
smears yes she's the real victim here
then she says the real problem here the
real problem is that
because iohan omar said something
anti-semitic she has now
undercut the anti-israel case she says
in truth while apex influence is
extensive no one needs to pay off
conservatives to make them support
israel
evangelicals a far bigger constituency
than american jews tend to be pro-israel
for religious reasons
not long after pelosi's statement omar
released one of her own apologizing
unequivocally
personally i'm happy to accept her
apology oh are you there's a giant ass
shock
that is a huge shock that michelle
goldberg is willing to accept a
completely insincere apology from a
member of her own political caucus
partisanship hell of a drug which is
progressive american muslims and jews
should be natural allies
our mutual future depends on deepening
this country's embattled commitment to
multi-ethnic democracy
prejudice helps bind the modern right
together but unchecked it can rip
the left it can rip the left apart so
she's very upset that ilhan omar exposed
the rifts inside the intersectional
coalition
instead ilhan omar should be
anti-semitically quietly that'd be the
best thing
if she could you know take that
anti-semitism and shove it back into the
anti-zionism anti-israel box then we can
all pretend that they're not
anti-semitic
they just don't like israel but they're
like jews they just don't like israel
or the people who live in israel who
happen to be jews
because the jewish state that shouldn't
exist because of the jews
so very solid stuff there from the media
that is not
the only media defense of the fresh
faces of the democratic party
best headline of the day okay so here's
the best headline of the day this one
comes
courtesy of the new york times i do love
it so
ocasio-cortez team flubs a green new
deal summary and
republicans pounce yes
i wish i could buy honestly i wish i
could buy stock in particular words
if i could buy stock and pounce i would
have bought stock and pounds like three
years ago
and man i would be a wealthy man today
because
the democrats have such supporters in
the media every time the democrats make
a mistake the story is republicans
pouncing
they're like young simba and the lion
king pounce there's
out of your pounds it's amazing all
these evil terrible republicans pouncing
on democrats
on democrats for their support of
infanticide
and racism and blackface and
anti-semitism
why won't these republicans stop
pouncing on innocent democrat
infanticidal maniacs why won't they just
stop their pouncing
the real problem here is the pouncing
obviously now i assume the editors at
the new york times
must know what they're doing here i
assume they know that they're just
tweaking people on the right if so it
just demonstrates their
their insane bias even more if not then
their bias is bad enough but if they
know what they're doing it's even worse
ocasio-cortez team flubs a green new
deal summary and republicans pounce
coral davenport reporting for the new
york times days after introducing her
green new deal
a plan to combat climate change that has
won the endorsement of several
democratic presidential candidates
representative alexandra ocasio-cortez
found the proposal enmeshed in confusion
when her staff published a summary that
included provisions not endorsed by the
candidates
okay a couple of things to note here the
fact and background check
the backgrounder and the frequently
asked questions document was posted
about two days
two days before the green new deal
resolution
hit the floor of the subcommittee in the
house so that's not even accurate
reporting it is not accurate
that all of these democrats endorsed the
green new deal and then ocasio-cortez
came out with a flub document she came
out the flub document
and then two days after that she was
forced to pull it down
because the green new deal came out
over the weekend her staff backed away
from the document saying it was
incomplete and had been published by
accident
after republicans pounced on the plan
citing a blog post of frequently asked
questions
it was not a blog post she put it up on
her own
campaign website she emailed it to
various media outlets
it's not a blog post ah this is what
passes for reporting at the new york
times the post included language that
called for economic security for all who
are unable
or unwilling to work the plan written by
ms ocasio-cortez a freshman democrat
from new york and senator edward mark of
massachusetts was modeled on fdr's new
deal and embraced by several
presidential candidates
it was also welcomed by senator bernie
sanders the sweeping resolution which
calls for the united states to eliminate
additional emissions of planet warming
carbon dioxide by 2030
was also signed by more than 60 house
and senate democrats the plan is a
non-binding resolution
and outlines goals and broad strokes
rather than mapping out concrete
legislation
spokeswomen and spokesman for senators
harris gillibrand booker and sanders
did not return telephone calls or emails
requesting comments on the error
so shouldn't that be the headline
shouldn't that be the headline
shouldn't the headline be every democrat
running for president who endorsed this
plan refuses to answer questions
about aoc's plan for the green new deal
shouldn't that be the headline how is
the headline republicans pounds how in
the world
is the headline republicans react to
things democrats did that's called
every day in politics in this country
every single day every single hour every
single minute
let's say that the sun rises this
morning and let's also say
that a famous person dies is the
headline sun rises in the morning or
famous person dies
you're adding no information news is
about breaking new information
presumably you're adding no information
by headlining that republicans react to
a thing democrats did
it would be significantly more important
information i would think
that democrats will not answer simple
questions
about what exactly aoc posted online
because they are so afraid of her on the
one hand and they are and they are
afraid to endorse her idiocy on the
other
ms uh i mean that's just unreal miss
ocasio-cortez has promoted the plan as a
blueprint for the eventual democratic
presidential nominee but republicans
have turned the episode with the
frequently asked questions
into a campaign moment putting out a
news release saying the document
revealed the extreme left's startling
priorities
that's the real story is that
republicans turned a democrat gaffe
into a democrat gap because that's never
happened before in politics
according to the new york times however
mistakes happen
mistakes happen that's this is the last
paragraph mistakes happen when
coordinating multiple groups and
collaborators
said aoc's campaign and chief of staff
what's in the resolution is the green
new deal oh okay well i'm glad that we
got all of that settled well done media
meanwhile
it looks like a budget deal is now on
the table it's not a very good budget
deal but
it's what president trump may get after
all of this hubbub according to the
associated press three people familiar
with congress's tentative border deal
tell the associated press that the
accord would provide 1.375 billion
dollars to build 55 miles of new border
barriers that is well below the 5.7
billion dollars president trump demanded
to build over 200 miles of wall
along the mexican boundary apparently
the money will be
will be for vertical steel slats called
ballers not a solid wall
democrats dropped their proposal to
limit the number of detained immigrants
caught inside the u.s to a daily average
of 16 500 republicans opposed that
demand
there is currently no such limit instead
bargainers agreed to fund 40
520 beds to detain immigrants entering
or in the united states illegally that
is the same number funded last year
but the actual figure held is around 49
000.
so in other words after all of this
president trump is not going to get any
more money than he would have gotten in
the original budget that was presented
to him by the democrats which included
1.7 billion
1.3 billion dollars to build whatever he
wanted it was just funding for border
security
he refused that he wanted more money he
didn't get more money but now he can
claim that there's some money to build
55 miles of new border barriers i
suppose sean hannity was livid about
this yesterday
on his fox news program as well he
should be this deal is a
garbage deal it doesn't give the
president anything more than he would
have had if he had never gone through
this rigmarole in the first place
and again democrats actually made it a
negotiating point to have fewer beds
available
to house criminal illegal aliens so that
they would be released
into the general population that's a
pretty amazing thing
so do i think that trump ends up going
for the deal i think there's enough
blowback from the right that trump ends
up declaring
a national emergency or having his
department of defense say that we need
additional wall building and additional
fencing
to stop drug corridors along the
southern border i think that's probably
the direction
that he is going to go politically it
makes more sense than signing off on
this deal but
if the president just wants to get past
it and move on to 2020 then he'll sign
this deal we'll all move on
he won't pay a serious price for this
with his base
honestly from political point of view i
get it from a we need a wall point of
view i don't get it
at all okay time for some things i like
and then some things that i hate so
things that i like today this is this is
pretty hilarious a bunch of college
students were asked about the green new
deal
and as per the usual arrangement around
the united states when college students
are asked about anything that sounds
like a left-wing proposal
they love it until they're told what's
in it this is true for every poll ever
taken when people are asked whether they
like socialism people like yeah
socialism sounds great they're like oh
yeah that'll be
60 taxes taxes on you and also we're
going to end your private health
insurance and like oh wait
hold up that's not as great that's not
that's not
particularly awesome okay so here was a
person from campus reform going around
asking college students about the green
new deal their responses are quite
hilarious
based on what you've heard of the plan
would you say you view it favorably or
unfavorably
i view it favorably i think that we need
to cut our reliance on fossil fuels
it's definitely a great idea i like that
it's uh progressive
i like that it is going to push the
world forward in the way we need to be
so the plan says within 10 years we're
going to completely
outlaw coal natural gas and oil so
gasoline anything like that in 10 years
i don't i don't agree with that to be
honest with you i think we need those
things to live
i do not think it is feasible in 10
years if you're
unwilling to work we will still supply
help for your salary and help for a
living wait
no absolutely not if you're not willing
to contribute to society
then i don't think that the people who
are contributing should
pay for you eliminating almost all air
travel with high-speed rails
which thought on that uh i think it's
kind of the same one it's like i think
10 years is a little extreme for that i
think that's drastic i haven't
heard of that one yet who's gonna pay
for all of it who's gonna offset
the trillions of dollar cost it would be
right i don't know
nobody knows based on what you've heard
from these does it change your
perception to plan at all
yeah a lot sometimes you need to take
extreme measures to save the environment
but i don't think that is like
i think it's a bit too extreme okay so
even
even even these college students are
realizing that these proposals are
insane which is why all trump has to do
is just let democrats make the proposals
and then he has to point out that these
proposals are in fact fully insane okay
time for a couple of things that i hate
okay so thing i hate number one
there's a pair of shoes that were
distributed by walmart
and katy perry i guess was was the
branding name on it
these shoes are just they they come in
black and they come
in yellow and they come in white like
they come in various colors and they
have eyes a nose and mouth on them
the only question you should be asking
about the shoes is why in the hell
anyone would buy them because they're
hideous
i mean i am not a fashion critic but
these are ugly ugly shoes but that is
not the question that people began
asking
the question people began asking were
were the shoes blackface
were the shoes blackface it's a shoe
that comes in multiple colors with just
eyes and nose and mouth on them
is it blackface like making fun of black
people
these are what we call first world
problems if you really believe
that katy perry designed a hideous shoe
specifically to make fun of black people
and you are deeply insulted by
a shoe and you think that the people
walking around in those shoes are
attempting to insult black people or
that you should feel insulted by a shoe
let me suggest that you need to get your
priorities in order these are not shoes
with swastikas on them these are not
shoes with confederate flags on them
these are shoes with eyes a nose and a
mouth on them
and yet they are now being seriously
these were now pulled from the shelves
because they were blackface shoes
we have lost our minds in similar news
hilariously
there is a shirt that was available at
bloomingdale's that said on fake news
and our journalistic firefighters
rushing to the site of the fire
to fight those fires every day they
rushed to the side of the fire
where they proceeded to say that those
fake news shirts had to be taken off the
shelves because if journalists stand for
one thing it's freedom of speech
that's the thing they stand for the the
shirts were removed
because anyone believed that the fake
news is fake news so
well done again journalists not all
heroes wear capes okay
final thing that i hate so bill nye who
is a science guy
by way of not knowing a lot of kind of
basic things about science shockingly
enough
um he did a video about abortion it is
the worst video
the worst pro-abortion video i have ever
seen it is just a giant straw man
against the pro-life movement but again
we're supposed to pretend that he knows
things because he wears a bow tie and
he knew like basic scientific stuff when
we were in third grade
when it comes to women's rights with
respect to their reproduction
i think you should leave it to women she
has rights over this
especially if she doesn't like the guy
that got her pregnant
like she doesn't want anything to do
with your genes get over it
if you're going to say when an egg is
fertilized it's therefore
almost the same rights as an individual
then who are you going to whom are you
going to sue whom are you going to
imprison
every woman who's had a fertilized egg
pass through her
it's just a reflection of a deep
scientific lack of understanding okay
he doesn't honestly god he's a
mechanical engineer okay he got his
career started as a mechanical engineer
and he doesn't know things first of all
he just equated miscarriage with
abortion and when he says every woman
who has a fertilized egg pass through if
you had a miscarriage
that's not an abortion what we are
talking about we talk in abortion is the
forcible ending
of an incipient human life that is what
we are talking about
and when he says that you should be able
to abort a kid because you don't like
the father
i mean it's hard to imagine a more evil
thing than that so if you get divorced
can you shoot your seven-year-old
if you really this is the logic the
logic is you don't like the person with
whom you share genetic material
and thus that genetic material loses all
right to exist
that's a pretty astonishingly broad
argument as you would say in law school
that's an argument that proves too much
but again we're supposed to pretend that
bill nye knows things because we called
him the science guy back when he wore a
white coat
and went and back by the way when he
used to say that male and female were
things that were determined by genetics
so that's that's good times for bill nye
the science guy alrighty
so later today we are on for two hours
this is why you should subscribe over at
dailywire.com
and get behind the paywall all sorts of
great stuff over there also tonight
speaking at university of alabama so
tune in to yaf.org
live to check that out we'll see you
then i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
senja villarreal executive producer
jeremy boring
senior producer jonathan haye our
supervising producer is mathis glover
and our technical producer is austin
stevens edited by adam syevitz audio is
mixed by mike caromina hair and makeup
is by jessua olvera production assistant
nick sheehan the ben shapiro show is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2019